- This is, literally, the biggest prawn
I've ever seen in my life.
To get a scale of this, I need
to put it up next to my face.
Here, this is almost as
wide as my shoulder torso.
(lively music)
Good morning, everyone, it's Mark Wiens
with migrationology.com,
in Lisbon, Portugal.
We are having breakfast
this morning at the hotel
before we go out for a full
day of sightseeing and eating.
Got some mushrooms, got some
scrambled eggs, got some fruit.
Oh, and also, I got some chorizo.
Mushrooms fried in butter.
I could not resist a couple pieces of,
this one is some kind
of chorizo, and then,
I'm not sure what this one is,
but look at that nice peppercorn in there.
Oh!
Oh, that peppercorn, fantastic.
And also, I should tell
you, it is, like, freezing!
I'm in shorts and a T-shirt right now.
I definitely need a jacket.
I wasn't expecting, it's really cold.
Not really cold, but it's very cool,
and this is the middle
of the summer in Lisbon.
(sipping loudly)
Ah!
Oh, yeah, this weather's amazing.
(laughs) And my hair's sticking up.
Can you see that, Ying?
- [Ying] Yeah.
- It's not like freezing,
but it's definitely kinda cool.
Oh, 18 degrees, and what
is that in Fahrenheit?
Ying, how do you change it?
Which in Fahrenheit is 64.
We are out now walking
around this cool morning,
on our way, heading
towards Castelo de Jorge.
(upbeat music)
We made it to the plaza of Dom Pedro IV
at Rossio, and so we're
just walking through here.
There are a couple of
fountains on either side,
and then right in the
center is the main statue
of Dom Pedro IV.
(upbeat music)
Before going to the castle,
while I'm in this area,
we decided to stop by
the Santa Justa Lift,
which is an elevator
that dates back to 1902.
And because the line
is not long right now,
I think I'm gonna go up
to the top right now.
(clicking)
On the lift now, about to go up.
(upbeat music)
How many floors is it up?
- [Woman] Floors, I'm not
sure, it's 42 meters high.
- 42 meters high.
- [Woman] With your ticket,
you just have to show it
to my colleague when
you go up there, okay?
- Okay, thank you.
And now, I am climbing
up the iron staircase,
circular iron staircase,
to the top viewpoint.
All right, made it to the top.
(upbeat music)
The elevator was designed
by Raoul Mesnier,
who was an apprentice of Gustave Eiffel,
and it's built of wrought iron,
and it was completed in the year 1902.
From up here, you get a
great sense of Lisbon.
You can see Rossio Square,
you can see the Castle of Sao Jorge,
you can see the cathedral,
as well as the waterfront in the distance.
(elevator creaking)
Thank you very much.
- Goodbye!
- Bye. (laughs)
Yeah, a vintage elevator in Lisbon.
We're on our way to the castle now,
which is just up the hill,
I can see a view of it.
And to save some time,
we're gonna jump on the bus.
(speaking in foreign language)
We made it on to bus number 737,
and we're gonna go up the
hill towards the castle.
It is a packed bus.
(upbeat music)
We really wound up the tiny
narrow streets here in Lisbon.
It was almost a roller coaster ride,
but we have arrived to
the top of the hill,
and welcome to the Castle of Sao Jorge.
(people chattering)
(beeping)
That cost 8.50 for entrance,
and this is a castle that is, maybe,
one of the biggest attractions in Lisbon.
It dates back to the 11th century
and was built by the Moors.
It's a citadel, so it's
on the top of a hill.
There's a castle, and
also on the same compound
is where there is a royal palace.
And also, from what I
was just reading in the
pamphlet that they gave
me, or the brochure,
this was also a privileged area of Lisbon,
where the elite lived.
And also, get some more
views of Lisbon from up here.
(upbeat music)
And I love how the entire fort
is just kinda sloping from how old it is,
and it's really nice,
lots of trees as well.
It's cool and shady.
(upbeat music)
Just a short walk to the
corner of the complex
is the actual castle itself.
There are 11 watchtowers
that still survive
within the castle,
and it was built as a military
fortress for protection
on a very strategic point in Lisbon,
right on the top of a hill in a position
where you can get a good view
and see the other parts of the
city, and people coming up.
(upbeat music)
You do have to be careful of the steps
because they're so well,
just like the roads and
the sidewalks in Lisbon,
they're so well-used that
they are smooth and slippery.
Whatever you do when you come up here,
you don't wanna slip and fall down.
(people chattering)
I think this is the tallest
tower of the castle.
(upbeat music)
From the castle, we decided
to just walk down the hill,
kinda curving, looping around,
and we're on our way to eat lunch,
but I'm loving this
walk through the narrow
medieval lanes of Lisbon,
and the buildings.
Awesome place to walk around and explore.
(upbeat music)
When you're walking around Lisbon,
it feels like you're half stumbling,
half losing your balance all of the time
because the sidewalks are so slippery,
and then so uneven,
with little sink holes.
And sometimes, the
sidewalks are so narrow.
This is such an awesome city.
We're on our way to go eat at
what is one of the most legendary,
and what almost everybody
says is the best,
the standard for seafood in Lisbon.
(silverware clanking)
(hissing)
And this is one of the ultimate, maybe,
I think it's the best from
what almost everybody says
for seafood in all of Lisbon.
We got here, luckily,
there was no waiting line,
but we did wait just
for about five minutes
for them to clear our table.
We're in here, I love
the lively environment.
You can smell the crab
and the shrimp in the air,
and the butter, in the
air of this restaurant.
And we just sat down and
they give you an iPad
for the menu.
All the different types of seafood.
Spiny dye-murex, whoa.
Tiger prawns,
crawfish, lobster, oysters, barnacles.
- (mumbles) One kilo (mumbles).
- Okay, one crab,
clams with garlic.
- Yes.
- And they have, just, an
amazing array of seafood.
And also, Portugal is known
to have some of the best
coastal seafood waters
of anywhere in the world.
You gotta love the lively
environment in here as well.
They have tanks of fresh seafood,
and then it actually feels like
a Chinese restaurant in here
although it's pure Portuguese.
Oh, wow, our first dish has just arrived.
(sizzling)
(speaking in foreign language)
Thank you.
Oh, thank you.
This one is the clams.
- Yeah, it's the clams in garlic sauce.
- Okay, (speaking in foreign language).
(loud chattering)
I'm, just, already
overwhelmed with seafood
and I haven't even taken my first bite.
(loud chattering)
Okay, seafood time.
While this is hot and fresh,
I am gonna take a bite.
These are prawns in garlic,
and I think that's butter.
And when he delivered it,
it was just bubbling over.
You can smell that aroma
of garlic in the steam.
Oh, wow, and it has stopped bubbling,
but I think it is still flaming hot.
(loud chattering)
Just pure goodness.
Oh, those are meaty and firm.
And along with those prawns,
what is exceptionally good
is how that garlic, just get
a really, really close up look
at that garlic.
It is half caramelized, so it's crispy,
yet it just has so much
garlicky-ness to it.
(laughing) Okay, one more, I have to.
On the menu, I think it said edible crab,
but I think it's a local crab
from the waters off Portugal.
And what is insanely
impressive about this crab,
as opposed to any other crab I've seen,
is the amount of eggs within the shell.
Look at that!
And they served it with
two spoons on the side,
it's like pudding.
(loud chattering)
Has just a very faint bitterness to it.
Just incredibly rich,
and you get little bits of,
I think they have, like,
they've sort of whipped it up, maybe.
And one more thing to
explain about the crab
is that it's served cold, so it's chilled.
It makes it refreshing, very refreshing.
I'm putting down the spoon and going in
for one of these hairy legs.
Oh, nugget, look at that
nugget of crab there.
Oh, you can actually feel the hairs
on this crab leg.
(loud chattering)
Whoa.
The juiciness of the crab,
it's so juicy, maybe because
of the way it's prepared,
and then how it's chilled.
(loud chattering)
Yeah.
That's just insane.
The other seafood dish that has come out
are the clams in garlic,
and I think butter as well.
Maybe I'll put some of
these onto my plate.
And these smell equally as
fantastic as those shrimp.
You can see all of those
pieces of garlic on it.
Oh, this one is covered in
sauce and butter and garlic
and goodness.
Oh, oh, he just slid out.
I wanna get all of that garlic though.
Actually, I will just pick this guy up.
(loud chattering)
That's stunning!
Little clam,
again, they are naturally
a little bit sweet,
and that is a salty, buttery,
just incredibly garlicky
goodness, buttery sauce.
And I think what they do here
is they bring a couple of seafood dishes,
and then once you finish
them, they bring some more
because if they were to
bring everything at once,
your table would just, actually,
everything would not fit on the table,
and your seafood would fall off the table.
So we just got three dishes now and then
some more will be coming.
What I need to do next is just
gather some of this garlic,
and just take an entire forkful of garlic.
Look at that, just caramelized, golden,
yet half raw at the same time.
(loud chattering)
Garlic is just one of the
greatest culinary gems
of anything, ever.
Next up, I am moving on to the crab claw.
And they give you a mallet
and a little hitting board.
(cracking softly)
Oh, you don't even need it on this.
Oh, that just popped right off.
Oh, and this just pops right off too, oh.
Okay, let me see if I can,
oh no, I broke off the
little claw on the inside.
Okay, I will come back for you later,
but I have to eat the drumstick.
Should I take this in one bite?
Yes, I think I should.
(loud chattering)
Whoa.
That is ridiculously flaky and stringy.
That is insane.
And what I love is that
it's such good crab that
it doesn't need anything.
I am already in a little
bit of a seafood shock
and high right now,
but we're only halfway done
with this seafood meal.
He has just brought the next course.
This is, literally, the biggest prawn
I've ever seen in my life.
And I also ordered some scarlet prawns,
but I thought these were
just gonna be little.
These are gigantic as well.
They're both huge!
If I just come back over here
to this giant tiger prawn.
To get a scale of this, I need
to put it up next to my face.
Just check this out!
This is almost as wide
as my shoulder torso.
I'm gonna set this guy down.
Guys, I'm in a little
bit of a shock right now.
I don't even know if I can describe
this with English right now.
Look at this beauty!
Wow, okay, I'm just gonna go
right into that mid-section.
Is this grilled or is it, I don't know,
but I think it's cooked in butter.
Oh, wow.
Oh, oh, yeah, I'm so happy I'm
using the knife upside-down,
and I don't even have
the energy to change it.
Oh, wow.
Okay, that's a good
enough bite for my first.
(loud chattering)
The firmness is insane!
It's so muscular, and
it's so juicy, again.
And it's salty and buttery.
Okay, I'm gonna go ahead and
peel off the entire shell,
maybe take out the entire flesh part.
And yeah, this would be
much easier with my fingers.
Oh!
(laughs) It's so meaty and so giant!
This is just ridiculous how big it is.
It's actually ridiculous.
All right.
Oh.
Wow, this is unbelievable.
And I will save that head for later.
Just look at the size of
the flesh of that body.
Okay, and then for this,
I think I'll squeeze out
a little bit of lemon.
(loud chattering)
All right.
(laughs) Look at that section!
That section, there
are gooey things in it,
there are pieces of muscular flesh.
(loud chattering)
That is insane!
It's buttery, it's creamy,
it's muscular,
it's a little bit salty.
I love it with that
squeeze of lemon on it.
That is actually unbelievable.
I'm, like, at an emotional high right now.
And just get one more
look at the outside shell
of this guy.
And he just brought out
the final seafood dish.
I think it's the final one I ordered.
And this is something I
have never had before.
This is a type of barnacle,
and I think they're
called goose barnacles.
These are very interesting,
bizarre-looking.
They kinda look like little animal hoofs,
but you can actually see the algae,
or some, like, green, something
seaweed growing off of them,
the algae from them.
These are very interesting.
I'm not even totally
sure how you eat them,
but I think you sorta just nibble off,
kinda break it apart,
and just nibble off all
of that outside material.
Oh, and when I squeeze
it, this juice runs out.
The end portion kinda
feels like a fingernail,
or like a hoof.
Yeah, really kinda looks
and feels like a hoof.
Okay.
(loud chattering)
Wow.
That's very sandpapery,
and very, like, leathery.
It sorta gushes with, like,
sea water taste to it.
(loud chattering)
I think that's the part
you're supposed to eat.
Oh.
Okay, that is pretty good.
It does taste kind of like a clam,
but a little more of a leathery clam.
Okay, so I think you take that out,
and you can kinda pry it open.
Oh, I think that's how you open.
Okay, and what you want to eat
is that thing on the inside.
Okay, a man, a nice man, family sitting
at the table next to me was
motioning me how to eat it.
There we go.
And you wanna eat that
little piece on the inside.
They just slip out.
Oh, yeah.
Moving on to my last prawn,
and this is a scarlet prawn.
(loud chattering)
And I honestly thought
these were just gonna be
the little, small prawns,
but these are just insanely huge as well,
in that deep red color.
I'm gonna delicately try
to break off the head,
maybe in his natural, oh no!
Oh, juice just came out. (laughs)
Okay, maybe turn it this way?
I wanna preserve all of that head juice.
Oh no, it is just falling
out onto the plate.
I don't think there's any way
to hold it in that little cup.
(cracking softly)
Oh, wow.
(laughs) There's a pool of shrimp head fat
on the bottom of my plate.
Just from peeling this,
I can feel how soft this prawn is.
Oh, and little pieces, slivers,
like strings of the prawn, are coming off
in the shell, which I will
have to come back and lick.
(cracking softly)
But you can feel, just, the
juices seeping out of this prawn
as I'm peeling it.
I'm gonna leave it at that.
This is not only a giant prawn,
but you can actually see, like, the veins,
and just strings running through it.
Wow!
(loud chattering)
While the tiger prawn
was meaty and muscular,
this is melt in your mouth.
You don't even need to chew it.
A baby could eat this prawn.
It's so soft and so tender,
and so juicy, again.
This will actually make you
go insane, it's so good.
Like, I didn't even need to use my teeth
to chew that.
I literally chewed with my gums.
(loud chattering)
I don't even wanna chew.
I just wanna tuck it
into the side of my cheek
and let it slowly disintegrate.
That deserves a moment of silence.
Thank you. (speaking in foreign language)
(loud chattering)
The only thing greater
than having these oysters
is having Nuno feed them to me.
I'm gonna go ahead and clean
off all of that barnacle juice
from my hands in preparation for dessert.
(loud chattering)
Oh, refreshing, lemony, lemony refreshing.
If my adjectives and my
words and my descriptions
don't completely line up correctly,
that's because I'm a little bit
seafood-intoxicated right now.
I'm not huge on desserts.
I don't like sweets very much,
but this is one dessert that I cannot wait
to dig into.
What you have to eat for
dessert when you come to Ramiro
is the prego, which is a steak sandwich.
Oh, and it is hot and fresh and warm.
Oh, you can feel the
tenderness of that bread.
And you open it up.
Oh, it's filled with steak!
Oh, and that beautiful pink,
oh, and you can see how the
juices have already soaked
into the bread.
But I absolutely wish you guys could feel
the softness of the bread.
It literally feels like a feather pillow.
(loud chattering)
This is a dessert to cherish.
That beef is so tender
and the bread is so pillowy!
That is absolutely amazing,
but I think I will add
a little bit of mustard.
Okay, and as I took off that bread,
that is another reason why it's so good.
It's topped with more garlic.
I love their use of
garlic at this restaurant.
(loud chattering)
Okay, that should be good.
That beef is incredible,
and the whole combination,
I can't even think of a better way
to have ended such a meal.
They know what they're doing here.
That was a stunner of a sandwich
after a stunner of a meal.
All I can literally do right now
is just sit back in my chair.
I'm even trying to just
comprehend that meal.
It was so good.
- [Nuno] Ice cream and lemon.
- [Mark] Ice cream and lemon.
- [Nuno] And vodka.
- And vodka!
But there's one more dessert
that Nuno has just given me.
I was honestly not expecting this at all.
Okay, gotta eat it.
Wow, that is like a slushy ice cream.
(loud chattering)
Wow!
That is lemon ice cream,
oh, but wonderful lemon.
That is, like, yogurty and icy,
and rich and creamy, and,
like, freshly lemony.
Oh, and with that splash of vodka,
that is awesome, actually.
That's really good, that's like
a complete palate cleanser.
Ying and I just managed
to spend 2-1/2 hours
at that restaurant, enjoying the food.
That was, literally, one
of the finest seafood meals
I've ever had in my entire life.
Everything was delicious.
The variety of prawns were just insane.
The staff were friendly, shoutout to Nuno,
who was our waiter.
That is a seafood paradise in Lisbon.
And I think for the
remainder of the afternoon,
we're just gonna walk around the center,
kind of coastline area.
(bright mellow music)
Before we get all the way down
to the bottom of the hill,
we're gonna make a stop
at the Lisbon Cathedral.
(bright mellow music)
This is the original, one
of the oldest cathedrals
in Lisbon.
Construction was started in 1147,
and it has been taken
over a number of times
by different civilizations,
but it remains one of the
ultimate landmarks of Lisbon.
I'm gonna go inside for a quick look.
The entranceway to this cathedral is huge!
And what you really notice
about this cathedral
is how thick the pillars and
the columns and the walls are.
I think it started off as a
Romanesque architectural design,
but since it's been through
so many civilizations,
other parts have been added,
so I know it has some
Gothic elements to it,
as well as some Baroque elements to it.
So, it's a mix of architectural styles.
(bright mellow music)
We made it to the central
Comercio district of Lisbon
and we are now walking up
to the Arc de Rua Augusta.
And it was built in 1755 to
commemorate the reconstruction
of Lisbon after a major, major earthquake.
(bright mellow music)
After already seeing
this plaza multiple times
from different lookout points,
we have finally made it
on the ground level here.
This is the Praca do Comercio,
and it used to be the site of a palace
until the palace was
destroyed in an earthquake
several hundred years ago,
and then it was made into a plaza.
It is an open space, a big
communal public gathering area,
and we're gonna go see
the Tagus River up close
for the first time.
(upbeat music)
And now, we have decided
to take the Metro,
and we are en route to go
have what is, hopefully,
some of the best Piri
Piri Chicken in Lisbon.
(upbeat music)
We just got off the Metro at Rato Station.
We arrived to the restaurant
right across the street.
It's called Frangasqueira Nacional,
and they are famous for
their Piri Piri Chicken.
There's a line outside,
but I think it's only
a takeaway restaurant.
I don't think they have
any seats in there,
so we're gonna get takeaway.
I'm not sure how long it's gonna take,
but I think it's gonna be worth it.
Every now and then, I will get
a whiff of the grilling smoke
coming out of the door.
Smells fantastic.
(sizzling)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Woman] Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you. (speaking
in foreign language)
- [Woman] Bye. (speaking
Enjoy (mumbles).
- Thank you.
That wait took about 30 minutes,
but as soon as I stepped inside,
that aroma of the grilling meat,
I probably have some drool
coming down my cheek.
And she said there's a
park just down the road.
I found a spot where I'm gonna eat
and there's a garden right behind me,
but it's kinda dark and shady,
so the light is better here,
'cause I wanna take some
photos of this chicken.
I got an order of potato chips.
These are fresh potato chips.
And then I also got a tomato salad,
which looks fantastic, with
some onions and oregano in it.
Oh, and it's hot and fresh.
I think these are the ribs,
and then also, I had
to get a whole chicken.
Oh, yes.
Okay, we just gotta take a
look at the chicken first.
Oh!
Oh, a little cloud of steam just came out!
I, literally, did not
wanna take another step
before trying this chicken.
Oh, and which piece?
Okay, this piece right here on the top.
This is a piece of the
breast with some of the wing.
That's awesome!
It's so smoky, and, like, charred.
(wind blowing)
(moaning satisfactorily)
Oh, and that's a combination of the oils
and the juices of the chicken,
plus all that sauce that he brushed on.
You have to have a close-up
look at that skin and that char.
(dog barking)
Oh, the drumstick is so
juicy, packed with flavor.
(moaning satisfactorily)
And I think the potato chips
have some oregano on them.
(potato chip crunching)
Mm, yeah, that's oregano.
And you can taste that they're homemade.
That just has such a big difference
from packaged potato chips.
Next up are the ribs, and I
think I got the same sauce
drenched all over it.
I can really taste the
chili oil on this one.
That chili oil is,
it's just a little bit spicy,
but yeah, it has so much chili flavor.
Oh, yeah, and again, that oregano,
that oregano is really good.
And then, again, that oregano.
And there are just a few onions.
I think she put olive oil
and lemon, or maybe vinegar
in here as well, so I
wanna take from the bottom,
as that has gone down.
(moaning satisfactorily)
Really fresh and juicy plump tomatoes,
and then the oregano comes in nicely.
(potato chip crunching)
I didn't finish it yet.
I just wanted to eat a
couple of drumsticks.
And actually, we packed it back up
and Ying and I are gonna
go back to the hotel
and finish it off, 'cause
it's getting cold out here.
It's actually really cold,
just like this morning.
So, I'm gonna end the vlog for today now.
Thank you all very much for watching.
Please remember to give
this video a thumbs up
if you enjoyed it,
and also, make sure you
subscribe for lots more food
and travel videos.
And Lisbon is just an outstanding city.
It's a beautiful city, fantastic culture
and mix of art and food.
It's just a great place and I am loving
this Lisbon trip so far.
I will see you on the next video.
(beeping)
Good morning, everyone, it's Mark Wienz
with migrationology.com in,
where are we? (laughs)
- [Ying] Portugal.
- Okay, we arrived in Lisbon.